[Applaudissements]
c'est l'animal
[Musique]
la médaille a pas de taper sur cette
boîte vous avez une minute
ouais t'as une minute oui ça va mettez
les mains arrêté ne mettez pas les pieds
non allez valérie roy carroll et kpatcha
va gagner un téléphone avoir gagné des
choses c'est parti valérie à décines
mettez vos mains attend les
téléspectateurs voient de quoi il s'agit
alemanno allez j attends qu à vous dire
il ya donc des papiers ou les récupérer
moi franchement je ne serais pas allé
non mais sérieux c'est ce qu'il ya de
pire c'est vrai les imminentes
je dirai ce que je me suis calé
important et je donnerai pas le cadeau
je me donnerai c'est chaud là les
grilles relâché sans confession à l'est
connaît avec moi veulent être contre
l'immense place mais maintenant oui vous
touche à la vallée mis fin à l'escaladé
des tensions
vraiment
ragot avait touché alesi et ce car selon
les nominés
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai moi je veux bien leur nom mais vous
allez ajouter 30 secondes et sera la
dernière a mis les mains d'or mais vous
êtes là à peine être les jeux je
m'appelle la masa me lâche pas
touchés tu vas tu dois aller chasser des
pyrénées vallée voilà elle opportune des
parties
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je râle mais non mais
[Applaudissements]
allez les gars y allez on y va aller là
elle peut être pas car il accorde à la
série quand on lui parle excuse moi
caroline la grotte à faire peur pour toi
caroline je vais pas
[Rires]
[Musique]
valérie il avait fait perdre car est ce
que vous les mettez vos mains mettez vos
mains mais donnez-moi vos mains
donnez-moi dans la capitale j'aime pas
qui me touche mais chez les arrête
mais oui mais c'est pour aller on y
enlève ta main et manu messiah c'est
l'animal gueule mais c'est l'animal
n'est pas la question
[Applaudissements]
j'atteins les syndicats
[Musique]